first question today will come from ben
goats of the las vegas review journal
hey guys uh max this question is for you
just what did the last three weeks been
like
from for you from getting injured in
training camp to having to wait to
go to the bubble to quarantining to now
yeah everything's been based around the
decision of how i'm gonna
uh be as prepared as possible before i'm
able to
return to play um i think as a group
everyone felt that give myself the best
opportunity by
doing some of the rehab process back in
las vegas
that went really well and when i came
here i had to
quarantine a little bit so tried to do
as much as i could in my room
to maintain my fitness levels and uh
thought it probably did as good of a job
as i could with that but nothing can
really simulate a playoff game so
just trying to work my my hardest to
make sure that i'm up to speed
when i do return next question today
i'll come from chris matthews of klas 8
in las vegas
hey i appreciate this guys can i just
ask you we talked to peter about this
but
just your guys's thoughts given all the
circumstances that's going into this
season's postseason
the bubble and all the restrictions and
so forth can you just kind of give me an
idea of how difficult
winning this year's stanley cup will be
and if you win this year
is it perhaps the you know the the
greatest win of any team just given all
the circumstances
really a question for both of you
i mean i i've said this from the
beginning and it's even more evident now
um now that we're here in the bubble and
we've been
here for the last couple weeks uh it's
it's hard
it's hard to um you know mentally
sometimes you know
you're used to being out and about and
what now you're stuck inside a hotel but
you're still good to play hockey and you
saw the first couple games you know with
us you saw the first playoff series were
incredibly intense guys are fresh a lot
of hits a lot of block shots guys really
playing hard and i think you know
the mentality of guys are here is that
you're here you're stuck in this bubble
you might as well come here and
and you know try and win the thing i
mean that's kind of been the
the way the feeling is around this whole
situation and
and it's it's been uh it's you know like
i said it's only been two weeks we
haven't really haven't even started the
playoffs yet technically and you know
day one starts today uh
it starts tomorrow and the journey
begins there but it's uh i think it's a
good like i said
a couple weeks ago i think this would be
the hardest one to win
next question today will come from greg
wizinski of espn.com
hey there nate good to see you again um
can you give me a sense of what it was
like amongst the boys
when the robin laner trade went down to
the trade deadline i mean you and a lot
of guys have
were original golden knights with flour
um to have somebody come in that you
know was going to provide competition
how was that sort of thing received and
what was sort of the reaction
when you see this goalie battle play out
between them
yeah i mean robin's have been an
established goalie in our league for
quite some time so anytime you bring in
somebody that's going to you know add
depth to your group ad you know
competition
it's gonna you know give a boost to your
team right he's an excellent player guys
been in the top of the vessel
you know voting like the last couple
years he's a
hey he's a guy that can come in and in
any circumstance and play well
and so for us it was um you know it's
hard to see a good friend of malcolm
subban go
um but you had a guy like with robert at
the deadline it just
really bolsters your team and
understands that this is uh
this is a you know you're coming here
for one thing and he's going to help you
win that
so um he's a guy that can step in at any
time
you know at the deadline it was how long
ago was that
i remember i remember what i felt like
at the deadline the previous lifetime
ago
but uh uh he's just like i said
he's uh he's really assimilated into our
group really well and like i said
he's gonna be a guy we're gonna need to
rely on
next question today will come from jesse
granger of the athletic
this one's for max i know you haven't
played any games up here but there have
been a lot of
penalties and and the power play minutes
have been high and as a guy who is a big
key piece to this power play i'm just
wondering how important you think that's
going to be and maybe if you're if
you're excited to get
maybe some extra minutes on the power
play yeah and
hopefully we do get that opportunity but
you still have to work for your power
plays i think we saw a game last night
that didn't show as many
um power plays so maybe you know the
calls will go down less and less as the
series move on um
but the power play is a good way to jump
right in and feel confident get some
puck touches um
you know we've shown that we've been
able to be a very capable power play of
changing games and
i want to come in and you know that's an
area i definitely want to try and help
the boys
next question today come from phil
thompson of the chicago tribune
hello uh this is from max just really
uh briefly it's been a long time uh
since you've
played uh the the hawks uh
do they look like the same team to you
you know
yeah i think no they don't look like the
same team
this is a new season we saw so many
teams get bounced already or
teams you know struggle that didn't
struggle during the year to find their
game right now but
um this is a new team they're they were
had a couple young guys obviously we
know who they are that
um you know from year one year two or
you know
every uh you know off season you have an
opportunity to improve especially as a
young player and i think they've had
guys that were able to take that time
and take their game to a new level so
um definitely seems like they have a
little bit more depth now in terms of
guys with experience or
are filling out their bodies and whatnot
so um
definitely not a team at all that you
can take lightly especially
you know given the fact that they've had
so much success with their veterans then
you sprinkle in some
younger guys that um you know have
really picked up their game
since this has started and you know it's
going to be a really fun series but
um can't at all look at what happened in
the regular season they're
they're a strong team with a lot of
firepower
next question today i'll come from david
shaina the las vegas review journal
hi max for you can you just speak to the
difficulty of leaving
family obviously wife expecting and and
just
you know being up there your situation
obviously a little different maybe
you have to say goodbye i guess a little
longer but how difficult
is that i guess for you yeah it's not
difficult i have a very supporting wife
kids and family
yeah my wife's expecting but this is
she understands that this is a she was
an athlete so understands that
as a young kid this was my goal my
entire life
so she's so excited uh that i have this
opportunity because it doesn't come very
often
so um you know with technology and when
i
get to still see the kids every day you
know you gotta look back at uh that
definitely wasn't the case back in the
day you had to leave your family and
no face time no cell phones you think
about people in the army who
who leave for long periods of time and
you know this is my job this is what i'm
paid to do and
i'm just thankful i have the support of
my family to try and accomplish my
dreams
next question today will come from
stormy bonne and tony of the vegas gold
knights
hey max just curious what you've seen
watching the team from afar and what's
impressed you about the way that the
group
has stood up against the three top teams
in the western conference
it definitely stands out that we did our
work over the break
the team looks like they're in shape
team looks sharp
i know we had a very strong training
camp because i i was in it and i saw it
but uh
it definitely shows uh once the game
started that
uh this team has their legs you know for
the entire game and
as uh i think a little bit of advantage
we feel we have
you know it starts to fade a little bit
because everybody's starting to get in
shape now
and uh you know really it's nice to have
that confidence uh
that some guys are able to kind of build
for themselves going into this playoffs
and
you know i think everyone should feel
good about their game right now and
and we really want that to carry over
once the playoffs do start
next question will come from justin
emerson of the las vegas sun
max i guess how strange was it to just
be in the bubble and be that close to
your
team but not be able to play and having
to watch the games on tv that are
happening a five-minute walk away
it was strange but as you mentioned at
least the entertainment was there's a
lot of hockey on i
had some weights and a stationary bike
in my room so tried to do whatever i
could to
stay in shape but the end of the day i
just found myself
working out and watching hockey so it
kind of helped me get back into the
groove of things
time for a few more questions today next
question will come from john deez
okay this one's for nate i just want to
circle back to what you were talking
about you know being in the bubble and
and this could be the hardest one to win
but i'm just curious do you think as the
playoffs go on the guys are going to
stay
fresher because you know you don't have
the travel back and forth across the
country like you guys had to do with
washington the hawks had to do with
anaheim in 2015 and then to tampa bay
now i've heard that takes a lot out of
guys do you think that's going to help
guys stay fresher and
better on the ice that's a good point
yeah i didn't really think of that
um definitely when you don't that
you know hop on a plane travel five
hours three time zones it's gonna be
nice
um we just walked to the other la walked
at the other bench for an away game
is uh something that's has to be a
little easier on the body i just
more mentally i guess um is something
that i think it's going to be
tougher physically might not be as hard
on your body which would mean that
a lot less travel would mean that you
feel a lot better when you do hit the
ice
i like i said it's uh it's going to be a
tough one to win
just no matter what given all the
circumstances but like the points you
alluded to the points that i alluded to
before is that there are a lot of
things that are going to help you know
guys be able to feel better for winning
you know puck drops and whether that's
first round
third round you know the final whatever
maybe i think
it's gonna be a long road but you know
at the same time it's
you guys are gonna be like i said a lot
more fresh than i think they have been
in years past i mean you got a lot of
time off and then
like i said no travel you're right here
every day so
it's not like you're moving much time
for two more questions we'll go to
william ramirez of the associated press
nate you've been with this team since
the start been to the stanley cup final
seen the potential of the first two
vegas teams since joining the league
um sort of carry over from what you just
answered because of the bubble the
circumstances maybe a tighter bond in
being
disclosed around one another for months
is this particular roster as
capable if not more so than the previous
two seasons to make a run
uh back to the final and win it yeah i
think
it really comes down to is um you know
we had a great run our first year
um second year things happened
this team's got a lot of firepower we
got a lot of depth in our forward group
that i think it really makes us even
more dangerous than we ever have been i
think we got guys that
up and down our lineup can score up and
down the lineup can defend well
penalty kill power play i mean um
you saw that uh you know you add a guy
like max back into our lineup and it's
just going to push another you know have
a ripple effect to our our team to have
you know that many more guys with skill
and speed you know up and down our
lineup and i think
that just is the biggest difference
between where we are now and where we
have been
um i think you see the
what happened in year one and what
happened last year as well you gotta
learn from those things and learn that
it's not gonna be easy you're not gonna
just walk back into the stanley cup
final you know it's
it's incredibly hard to get there and
i think that our guys are understand
that and and understand
that uh you know last year we thought
maybe you could just roll through a team
and once you're up and now we learned
the the valuable lesson that that's not
going to happen and we're playing a very
good team here in chicago it's a
it's a team that just you know played
really well out played you know edmonton
and uh
you're gonna have to have your best game
moving forward here and
and uh in order to beat this team in the
first round last question today will
come from david shaina the las vegas
review journal
i need for you can i know it's kind of a
time and space issue but just
touch on their high-end skill defending
them and and especially patrick kane in
his shot what makes that difficult
yeah i mean patch talked a little about
this before you got guys
you sprinkle in some young really good
young talent with some
guys that have been you know all-star
superstars in our league for quite some
time and
you know anytime you do that and they
start clicking it's it makes it
difficult to defend against i mean
patrick kane's one of the hardest guys
to play one-on-one in the league
and it's not just defenseman it's how
our forwards pick them up how our
forwards come back hard and help us out
that allows us to play our gaps a little
bit tighter because that's what's going
to frustrate
um skilled players if we can be up in
their face the
entire series and and make it hard and
make them go through you instead of
you know give them the time space to go
around you and make plays through you
um that's going to be the big key to
this series
especially for you know our group is is
eliminating that time and space and
having a good pushback from our forward
group
and you know and it always comes down to
this is good goaltending so that's
always what it comes down to in series
like this
thank you max thank you nate thank you
to the members of the media for joining
today this will conclude the vegas
golden knights media session